schauen sie mal das sind die fakten die
sechs fakten für die freiheit
die omikron welle ist gebrochen die
sieben tage instituts und der anteil
positiver pcr test fallen seit
donnerstag geht auch der wert nach unten
omikron ist fast fünfmal weniger tödlich
als delta weniger als einer von 1.000
omikron infizierten stirbt an der
krankheit
dauerhaft wenig intensiv belegung die
zahl der intensivpatienten liegt seit
drei wochen unter
2.500 wie kliniken erwarten keine
überlastung mehr
omikron wird soll neben diagnose bei
immer mehr offiziell gemeldeten corona
patienten wurde das virus nur nebenbei
festgestellt
weniger ansteckungen bei schülern nicht
mal zwei prozent der ansteckungen kommen
aus der schule außerdem die instanzen
bei kindern sinken und die impfquote ist
höher als gedacht im oktober hatte das
lka eingeräumt dass viele impfungen
nicht gemeldet worden seien das ist bis
heute so